>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Rob Casper: Hello and welcome
to the Library of Congress.
My name is Rob Casper, I'm the
head of the library's Poetry
and Literature Center here,
and I could not be more excited
to celebrate the
50th anniversary
of the acclaimed essential
International Writers Program
at the University of Iowa.
It's a historic occasion for
literature and for our country.
I would like to take
this opportunity
to thank not only
IWP for being here,
but also thank our presenting
partners, the Hispanic division
of the Library of Congress
and the Bureau of Educational
and Cultural Affairs at the
U.S. Department of State.
Before we begin, let me ask you,
since you are all taking
pictures of yourselves,
why don't you just
put them on silent.
I'm going to turn mine off just
to make sure they
don't interfere
with the recording event.
This is being recorded and we'll
have a Q&A section at the end.
By participating in that
section, you give us permission
for future use of the recording.
Second, let me tell you a
little bit about the Poetry
and Literature Center.
We are home to the
U.S. Poet laureate;
our current poet laureate is
Tracy K. Smith and we put on 20
to 30 programs like this
one throughout the year.
In fact, next week on November
9th, in honor of Veterans Day,
we are featuring Pulitzer Prize
Winning Poet Yusef Komunyakaa
reading his favorite poems
of World War I in honor
of our exhibit upstairs,
Echoes of the Great War,
American Experiences
of World War I.
To learn more about
the programs that we do
and programs sponsored
by not only the Poetry
and Literature Center, but
also the Hispanic Division,
you can sign our signup
sheet out in the foyer.
You can also visit our
website www.loc.gov.
Speaking of the Hispanic
Division, I know most of you got
to check out the collections of
Gabriel Garcia Marquez 100 years
of solitude books
that we have there,
curated by our reference
librarian Heather Gomez.
If you haven't had a chance
to check them out, you should.
They're wonderful and
exciting and show the history
of that book, which we'll
talk about in today's program.
You can read about the
participants in today's program
in your print program,
you should all have
one at your seat.
But I need to introduce
Chris Merrill,
the longtime director
of the IWP.
Chris Merrill has published
six selections, six collections
of poetry including Watchfire,
for which he received the
Lavone Younger Poet's award
from the Academy
of American Poets.
Many works of translation
edited volumes, among them,
The Forgotten Language
Contemporary Poets of Nature
and six books of nonfiction.
His work has bravely
been translated
into nearly 40 languages.
And his honors include a
Knighthood in Arts and Letters
from the French government.
His journalism also appears
in many publications.
As Director of the IWP,
Merrill has undertaken cultural
diplomacy missions for
more than 50 countries
and I can say personally
that Chris is a tireless,
inspiring advocate for
writers and writing.
Please join me in welcoming
and congratulating
Christopher Merrill.
[ Applause ]
>> Christopher Merrill:
Thank you, Rob.
It's a thrill to be here today.
The IWP has had the good luck
to partner with the Library
of Congress for the
last several years
and this year is an
especially rich moment for us.
So, I'm going to read just
a tiny little introduction
to what we'll be doing today.
Many years later, when he
faced the firing squad,
Colonel Aureliano Buendia was to
remember that distant afternoon
when his father took
him to discover ice.
So, begins 100 years
of solitude,
Gabriel Garcia Marquez's
masterpiece,
which was published 50
years ago in Buenos Aries
and is widely regarded
as the key text
in the Latin American boom,
the literary Renaissance
of the 1960's and 70's that
reshaped world literature.
The Columbian novelist,
journalist and Nobel laureate,
Garcia Marquez and fellow
writers like Jorge Luis Borges,
Julio Cortazar, Jose
Donoso, Carlos Fuentes
and Mario Vargas Liosa were
not only bold explorers
of foreign history and politics,
but also influential
thinkers whose works continue
to inspire intrepid spirits
to strike out on their own.
Take that opening sentence,
which brings together a wealth
of dispirit elements, a firing
squad, a visit to an ice house,
a father and son past and
present in the service
of what critics from
term, magical realism.
A vision of the human condition
that resonated around the world.
In that same year, 1967, the
American poet, Paul Engle
and his soon to be second wife,
a Chinese novelist Nieh Hualing
hosted the first residency
of the University of Iowa's
International Writing Program.
Engle had directed the Iowa
writers workshop for decades
and upon his retirement,
Hualing convinced him
to start a similar program
for writers from abroad,
what he called the craziest
idea he had ever heard.
Then he and Hualing proceeded
to build the IWP believing
that distinguished foreign poets
and writers would welcome the
chance to spend three months
in Iowa City working
and exchanging ideas
with their counterparts
from other lands.
In this, the Engle's anticipated
Kevin Costner's famous line
from Field of Dreams, a film
set in Iowa and based on a novel
by a graduate of the
writer's workshop who wrote,
If You Build It They Will Come.
With funding from the
U.S, Department of State,
the university arranged
through philanthropic sources
and through bilateral
agreements, the IWP has hosted
over the last half century,
more than 1,400 writers
from 150 countries,
including 189
from Central and South America.
The IWP, included in this
are two prize winning,
two Nobel laurates, Orhan Pamuk
from Turkey, Mo Yan from China,
best-selling writers from every
continent and major boom figures
like Jose Donoso, the Chilean
author of The Obscene Bird
of the Night, as well
as post boom writers
like Luisa Valenzuela,
the Argentinean author
of the Lizard's Tale
and Gustavos Sainz
the Mexican author
of the Princess of the Palace.
In short, the IWP
brings together writers
from distant lands in the
service of literature,
that magical arena in which all
manner of memory's, impressions
and stories continue, combine
to address the complicated days
and nights of characters
real and imagined
and cultural diplomacy which
has been defined as the exchange
of ideas and information.
The result, on the one
hand, poems and novels,
plays and films, essays
and nonfiction works,
all seeking to bear witness
to our walk in the sun
and on the other hand, the
gift of cultural exchange,
which is the capacity
to entertain a larger,
more nuanced understanding of
the infinitely diverse peoples
with whom we share this earth.
That's the theme of what
we'll be talking about today
and we'll begin with Cynthia
Schneider, the professor
from Georgetown who has,
who probably knows more
about cultural diplomacy
than anybody on the planet.
Cynthia.
[ Applause ]
>> Cynthia P. Schneider:
That's a [inaudible] idea
but thank you, thank
you very much.
And it's really wonderful
to be here.
I don't want to take up
too much of your time away
from these wonderful writers
we're going to hear from.
But I think I'm going to begin
by quoting a Dutch historian
who said, Johan Huizinga
who said,
if you want to understand
America, read Walt Whitman,
and after that, watch
American cinema.
Now, this idea that you
understand a country
through its writers,
through its creative writers
who of course are also
involved in cinema is
such an important idea, I
think, and I wish very much
that it was an idea
that policy makers
in America not only
believed in but practiced.
I have been trying for the last
10 years to integrate politics
and culture to try to
persuade policy makers here
that culture is not
just a nice thing
that you praise once a year
at the Kennedy Center Honors,
but actually something
that is essential
to international relations.
If you look around you can
see how successful I've been.
But, this idea came to me
when I had the great privilege
of serving as U.S.
Ambassador to the Netherlands
under President Clinton and
there, I came to that position
as an art historian and in
that position I could see
first-hand the power of culture
in the context of diplomacy
and with all due respect
to the State Department
colleagues here,
they are not implicated
in this, I also could see
that the State Department just
didn't take culture seriously.
It just puts it to one
side and so I have tried
through my position at
Georgetown to embrace other ways
and initiatives to try to
demonstrate the importance
of culture in diplomacy and
the role I think is captured
by great Nigerian playwright
novelist, Wole Soyinka,
who said at the one national
conference on cultural diplomacy
that was held in November,
2000, at the White House,
Soyinka said, and
I'm condensing,
culture humanizes,
politics demonizes.
And I think, you know,
we've never been more aware
of the latter phrase
than we are today.
And this kind of
separation of culture
and politics was not always
true in the United States.
Interestingly, at
times of conflict,
and I would argue we are
in a time of conflict now,
when in times of conflict
the U.S. Government
and policy makers
turn to culture
and have played a
very important role.
I'll give you two examples.
One in Latin America, in 1941
there was a symbiotic aligning
of the stars when animators
in Hollywood went on strike
and the U.S. Government, taking
advantage of this, asked,
invited Walt Disney to create
a couple of animated films
for the Latin American
audience with the goal
of stemming the tide
toward fascism in the lead
up to World War II
in South America.
This was kind of an amazing
idea when you think about it.
And if you think
that is amazing,
what is even more incredible
is that the government,
instead of just saying OK go
make movies for Latin America,
sent Walt Disney and
his whole animating team
on a nine-week tour of Latin
and South America to try to,
incredible idea, understand
the audience and see
where they are coming from.
And create films that will
be, you know, appropriate
and understandable
and meaningful
in some way in that context.
And there's a wonderful
documentary about this made by,
directed by the son of one
of the animators called Walt
and El Groupo, that's
what they were called.
And it's based on the
letters they wrote back,
because of course that was the
means of communication then.
And they produced
a couple of films
that really were
quite successful.
Did they, you know, they didn't
say resist totalitarianism,
they had particularly
independent minded speaking
birds and you know,
things like that.
But I've had students who said,
oh yes, I remember those films,
my parents always
talked about those films,
they loved those films.
And so, there is one example
and the other is, I think,
very well known to you, the use
of culture during World War II.
I'm sorry during the Cold War,
and I think what's best known is
of course the jazz musicians
who travelled all over the world
and I think such an
important point to make
about that particularly
in today's climate,
is that these are of course
mostly African American
musicians travelling as
ambassadors of a government
that suppressed them horribly
at home in the United States,
this was during the era
of extreme segregation
and the Jim Crow laws.
And what made an
incredible impression
on audiences abroad particularly
behind the iron curtain,
but in any country with
a totalitarian government
which was most countries they
visited, was that these artists,
they were there to play
music and they did,
but if anyone asked them
about their life at home,
they were very honest about it
and what I think is
most commendable is
that the state department
that sent them knew that.
There's a famous story in
Dizzy Gillespie's autobiography
where he says, they
wanted me to go
to some briefing
before the trip,
but I don't need any briefing,
I know what this country is
and I have my own story to tell.
Well, the people who sent
him knew that and sent him.
And nobody said, oh you're just
musicians, you can't speak,
you don't have anything to say.
And it was this very
freedom of expression
that was not only tolerated
by the U.S. Government,
but actively supported
and actually funded,
that made such an
extraordinary impression.
But what we understood in the
Cold War, and I think that's
so important in today's
context, was it wasn't just
about sending American's abroad,
we also spent a phenomenal
amount of money,
some say up to a million
dollars a year, publishing
and distributing rush
literature from Eastern Europe
and particularly from Russia.
It was the United States that
got Dr. Zhivago out of Russia
and [inaudible] writings
and not only that,
but also distributed
them inside Russia.
So, there was a recognition
of something so important
that it's not just about
sending Americans around
and American's writings around,
but it's about leveraging local
voices, which was something
that really just the United
States had the capacity to do.
And getting that word out,
getting those creative voices
out and telling the world what
was the story of the Gulag
and disseminating it within
the vast, then, Soviet Union,
was so important in
seeding the idea of freedom
and seeding the idea
of a different system.
And when you look at the
situation we're in today,
we are locked in a kind
of ideological battle
and what's our answer?
Drones, special forces,
you know, that has a role,
but we're really
talking about ideas here
and we have amongst our
writers in every country
that is problematic in this
war against extremists,
also has their own writers.
Very often they're suppressed
by their own governments,
and I wish that we would spend
as much attention and learn
from our own history, lifting
up those writers and the ideas
and the vision and
the imagination
about individual freedoms
and a different kind of life,
a life that's appropriate
in that place.
And, you know, we have
the capacity to do that
and I think the State
Department's support
for this wonderful program
shows that, you know,
we know how to do this, at
least in the United States.
I just wish the people in
the regional bureaus dealing
with all these countries
would take this seriously,
because it's a very
serious thing,
the incredible work you produce
and everyone should take it more
seriously, even when it's funny.
[ Applause ]
>> Christopher Merrill: And now
for the State Department,
Amy Storrow.
>> Amy Storrow: Thank you.
I'm looking forward
the Q&A afterwards,
we might have [inaudible].
Thank you, Rob, thank you Chris,
thank you Iowa and thank you ECA
for this invitation today.
It's really a pleasure
to be here.
I'm going to tell four
short, tiny stories
and then draw some
conclusions from them.
I'm kind of an odd bird
in the State Department
in that I myself have a Master
of Fine Arts and
Creative Writing.
And I wanted to begin by telling
the story of my taking the exam
to get into the Foreign Service.
There was a structured day where
they run you through all sorts
of tests and at the end
of the day they say,
is there anything you'd like
to talk about, and I said yes,
I'd like to explain why
a Master of Fine Arts
and Creative Writing is
excellent preparation
for the Foreign Service.
And this was my argument, first
of all it produces good writers
and you can't write well
if you can't think well.
Secondly, it produces
people who have read deeply,
and if you've read deeply,
you have an understanding
of human consciousness
that cannot be gotten
in any other way and what could
be more important for diplomacy.
It also means that you've
spent extensive time
in creative writing workshops
which means telling
people things very gently
that they don't want to hear.
[ Laughter ]
So that they absorb them
and telling them things
that they do want to
hear that they'll dismiss
because they don't want
to be embarrassed by them.
So, that was the background
that I came in with.
I guess that speech
was successful.
My second tour I had the great
privilege of serving in Scopje,
Macedonia as a cultural
affairs officer there.
And when I arrived within
a day or so I learned
from the cultural
affairs specialist there,
[inaudible] that the famous
writer, Caroline Forche,
was coming for the Scopje,
for the [inaudible] festival
and I had met her when I was
19, and I was dazzled, you know,
I thought this was
like Mick Jagger coming
to the states or something.
So, she came and
she was spectacular.
She loved the community there.
She met, as did I, Vladimir
Martinovski, and the thing
about it was that, you
know, back in the states
if I told somebody, even
if I told, to be honest,
my fellow Foreign Services
officers at the embassy,
a famous poet is coming, they'd
say, oh Amy, that's an oxymoron,
there's no such thing
as a famous poet.
But there she was, she was
like the Dalai Lama, you know,
she was on the front page
of all the newspapers.
She did major evening
talk shows, they loved her
and she came back more than
once, I believe, since then.
What that taught
me is that although
in America we have ideas
about poetry as a kind
of niche activity, sometimes
in a high culture context,
the rest of the world poets and
writers are public intellectuals
and they are here
to, to a degree,
but sometimes they've been
usurped lately by comedians.
Also, there I met Nikola
Madzirov, who was a,
IWP graduate who went
on to great success.
Caroline and I kind of
badgered poor Chris to make sure
that he got into the
program, and he went on to,
his work is now available
in more than 30 languages
and he's one of the,
often called one
of the most powerful
voices in European poetry.
That resonated for me what, the
hunger for poetry and so I drew
from work of a group that I
used to work with called Writers
in the Schools in
Houston, Texas,
and decided that what we needed
were the writers and residents
that are American spaces, which
are like small branch libraries.
So, a woman named Merilee
Cunningham agreed to come
and she spent a week
in residence at each
of our three American spaces
teaching creative writing
to young people.
That program went so
well it spread to Serbia
where she worked in all of
their American spaces there,
and I also brought a
different writer, Tilapia.
The thing about that too was
that there was Merilee
Cunningham
on the morning talk show,
because in Macedonia
at that time, the idea
of formally teaching creative
writing to young people,
that is teaching
critical thinking skills,
that is teaching how to think
clearly, was not something
that was taken for
granted as an activity.
My third little story is
my previous job I was head
of the alumni office at
the Bureau of Educational
and Cultural Affairs and there
we launched a program called
Washington Circle, which
is an online talk show.
So, we had the privilege of
having the poet, Edward Hirsch,
as a guest to talk about
civic engagement in the arts.
And he was a spectacular
guest but I think the thing
that really struck me
was that the room that,
we did this in the Foreign
Press Center in New York,
was full of exchange students,
current exchange students
and there were a bunch of
people there from China and one
of them, and he was talking you
know about all kinds of work
and he mentioned Chinese poets
and I think someone thought,
haha, I'm going to play gotcha
with Ed Hirsch and said,
well you know, could you
talk about some Chinese poets
that have really influenced you?
He said, well you know, for
example, Li Po, and they just,
they were staggered, so I think
it's really this idea to go back
to what Ambassador Schneider
was saying, of mutuality,
that Americans certainly
don't know all the answers
about everything, nobody does,
but people to people exchanges
are really, really integral
for building common shared
language and shared values.
And I wanted to also highlight
for you that the next episode
of the show will be on
November 8th at 2:00 p.m.
and it will feature Margot Lee
Shetterly who is the author
of Hidden Figures,
which became a film.
So, if you can watch
that, please do.
So, what do we make
of all of this?
Why does it matter?
I'm going to argue two things.
First, that there are
intellectual gains
at the individual level, which
everybody here already knows.
Creative writing in particular,
it's the most complex
and nuanced form of freedom
of expression that we have
as human beings, that's verbal.
With writers in the schools,
that group that I worked
with way back when, and that
group, the two poets who came
to Eastern Europe, they've
done a bunch of studies
about the impact of their
work and what it shows is,
and this was a third party
evaluator from University
of St. Thomas, the
students who participated
in the program showed measurable
gains in writing skills
and confidence in writing
and creativity as well
as an overall increase
in standardized test scores
compared to a controlled group
who did not participate
in the program.
And these are evaluations that
have been going on since 1999.
So, at the societal level,
what that programs does,
and many others like it, and
the work that you do, you know,
you who are participants,
is you create the core
of an educated citizenry,
and there's nothing more
than important than that.
Another thing at the societal
level is that you are all,
you know, a core of public
intellectuals and I wanted
to highlight Vladimir
Martinovski's work for a second.
I reached back to the Post and
asked them, what would then
like me to say here at
the Library of Congress,
and they wanted me to
talk about Vladimir's work
with the professor's
[inaudible].
The main goal is to
ensure independence
of higher education institutions
and the work and freedom
of expression that then spread
from that goal to a wider range.
So, poets are civic activists,
it's built into your DNA
because you care about words
and you care about thinking
and you care about people.
And we need you, so thank you.
We know there are many
distinguished members
of the IWP.
For those of you who are
current participants,
I want to highlight some
opportunities that are available
to you through the
Office of Alumni Affairs.
When you get back home,
please do, you know,
knock on your embassy's door
or call them, and ask to talk,
if you can, say that you want to
get involved if you have time,
teach some workshops,
do something, give back,
I know that you want to, I know
that's built into who you are.
There are programs
through the alumni office,
the address is Alumni.state.gov.
I particularly want to highlight
for you the alumni
engagement innovation fund
which offers grants of up
to $25,000 for programs
that you design yourselves.
It's a competition that we'll
launch again in February.
Because I asked for you, what
will you do with your success?
What will you do with
your medal that you wear
as a public intellectual?
And I thank you for that
and for your time today.
[ Applause ]
>> Christopher Merrill:
Thank you Amy.
I do want to say that
you're welcome to visit us
in Iowa City anytime you like
because that's the one place
in America where if you
tell someone you're a poet,
they're excited about it,
which is why we are
a city of literature.
Next, we're going to turn to
Santiago Giralt, our film maker,
novelist, writer of screen
plays from Argentina.
>> Santiago Giralt:
Thank you very much.
Well, I will mix a little bit of
biographical with a little bit
of some historical ideas.
I want to talk about
international changes
versus cultural isolation.
When I was five years old,
my sister, one year older,
started studying English
in an English Academy.
Back then I wanted to
do everything she did,
she was like my twin sister.
So, she taught me how to
read a year before I supposed
to learn it in school.
I convinced my mother to go to
the same lessons that she went
at the English Academy
and a few weeks later
after the classes started,
my mother received a phone
call from the academy.
At first, she worried
because a phone call was not
like an ordinary thing.
It was not about my
sister, it was about me.
Christina, the woman said on
the phone calmly to my mother,
you have to pay the tuition
for your younger kid.
He's participating in
class, solving problems
on the chalkboard, and
honestly seems more interested
in the language than
your daughter.
So, I started reading English
and Spanish almost
at the same time.
Years later there was a famous
French song called Joe Le Taxi
by Vanessa Paradix.
I love this song in
French, I asked my mom
to send me to the [inaudible].
I've never forgotten the basics
of the language I
learned in those days.
American, British, Irish
writers made me love English.
I consider myself an anglophile.
Television sitcoms, subtitled
movies and books did the rest
until I had some time to immerse
in the language when I was 19
and I spent a year abroad.
With my French, I used to
go stronger with [inaudible]
after I discovered
Marcel Proust and I wanted
to enjoy the [inaudible] themes
without subtitles and I hope
to live to learn much more
languages, I love languages.
I decided to be a
writer in a country
where we have already one
sacred cow, Jorge Luis Borges.
And at least a few other
international representatives,
[inaudible].
Many people ask me often, more
often than I would expect,
how could you write under
the influence of [inaudible],
I just respond, he is
my influence as much
as Marcel Proust in
Virginia Wolf or John Irving.
My nation is human kind,
my influences are not
localized geographically.
I would also ask that same
person, how could you write
after Cervantes and there
would be no Spanish literature
to be begin with.
So, after the Latin American
boom, a literary phenomenon
that meant an expansion of Latin
American literature in the world
and some of Argentina
in particular.
After that, in Argentina
we had a big dictatorship
then democracy.
And after the crisis of 2001,
a few years of populous
government.
After the crisis of 2001 the
politicians in Argentina had
to reveal the identity and
the confidence of the nation
by focusing only on internal
affairs on local culture.
As a result, the politics became
a way to reimagine Argentina
within its own borders
and a result of this,
a new form of naturalism and
cultural isolation emerged.
It's like the country
closed on itself
and we started getting less news
about international affairs.
It was all about Argentina
as if it was the only
thing that mattered.
So, populism focused their
attention on the needs
of Argentina and recreated
them to the fractured nation.
But the breech ran deeper
and deeper and after 12 years
of populism the rich became,
the crack became an abyss.
Now a day's society
is divided in two
and the two fractions fight each
other in a silent civil war.
And cultural isolation
became stronger and stronger.
In Argentina there is only one
big airport and less than 5%
of the population travels
beyond the bordering countries.
It is a hard place for a
free thinker and an artist
who doesn't think the needs
of Argentina history
are untouchable
and who questions
many of the ideas
that constitute the
nations identity.
Actually, my first
novel is about an affair
that [inaudible] had
with a 14-year-old girl.
So, imagine how I embrace
the Argentinian [inaudible].
I am an Argentine who doesn't
eat meat, I love traveling and I
like to discuss all the time
about the meats of Argentina.
So, where is my haven,
where did I find my haven?
First, in the foreign
languages that I learned
in visiting other cultures,
living inside a foreign land,
which one that is not
your mother tongue,
is finding an adopting nation.
To expand this concept,
art has become my nation.
For example, I studied a year
cowriting and directing a play.
I had to learn many
words, for example,
every piece of clothing is
called differently in Spain.
A sweatshirt we call
buzo, it's called sudadera
and the name we use in Argentina
means for them a diver.
A woman's sweater, a pullover
for us, would be a [inaudible],
name that came from
the Hitchcock movie,
and they use now for
the piece of clothing.
And so that's why I had
to understand the nuances
of the culture in order to
understand basic things,
and we are talking about
things like clothing.
I spent the last 11 weeks
in Iowa City sharing
in the International
Writing Program
with 34 other participants.
Every time we had a discussion
about gender, sexuality,
politics, I felt like I was
walking on broken glass.
Understanding the boundaries
of every culture was
a fundamental aspect
of this experience.
Creating a common ground
to share our experiences
was another one.
Artistic exchanges are a way
to break cultural isolation,
or at least they are for me.
It creates a land of exploration
for many people beyond the
boundaries of their own country
or region and allows people
to build a temporary society
with temporary rules that
apply to everyone involved.
These rules allow the group
to understand its own need.
[ Inaudible Conversation ]
So, these rules allow the group
to understand its own needs
and to explore dynamic forms
of organization, gender, race,
religion, sexuality, systems of
belief, are obliged to coexist
in a parallel society,
a micro cosmos
that reflects all societies.
In my own experience, it pushed
me to go beyond my comfort zone
and explore the beauty
of human bonds.
It's a way to remember
how societies are built
and how human forms of
organization emerge.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Christopher Merrill:
Thank you Santiago.
And now our last speaker is Enza
Garcia Arreaza from Venezuela,
fiction writer and poet.
And I've just learned
a fellow lover
of Joseph Brodsky,
the poet laurate.
>> Enza Garcia Arreaza:
Well, thank you so much
for having me here, it's an
honor to be in Washington
as a resident in International
Writing Program and I want
to say this, it's an honor
to be in front of you,
my colleagues in the program.
For the last time
at least for once.
[ Foreign Language ]
Some years ago, a prominent
writer from my country asked me,
why do you plan to
publish a book with a title
of The Forest of Birches?
In Venezuela, evidently,
we don't have birches
or snow or [inaudible].
He said, you should write about
what you know, about real life,
about your difficulties of
finding a house is Caracas,
about being sad and poor.
So, one day you will discover
that you must face and deal
with stupid people who
use an abject nationalism
to keep you in your place.
Classists are as
uncomfortable with themselves
as with the rest of the world.
For me, first as a reader,
and then as a writer,
opening my arms and my mind
was the most obvious approach.
My national boundaries
were a blur
between [inaudible]
coordinates that sooner
or later will become part of
my most intimate landscape.
Sometimes I get to like the
person I am and that's thanks
to the poets of my country.
Eugenio Montejo, Juan
Sanchez Pelaez who was here
in the residency in Iowa,
[inaudible], just to name a few,
but I'm also Elliott, Blake,
Milton, [inaudible] Brodsky,
especially Brodsky,
especially Broksky, [inaudible]
and also Iranian music, and the
Irish [inaudible] and colors
and flavors that
scare or confuse
but suddenly give you
back to the kitchen
of your own grandmother.
We should go beyond
the act of surviving.
We should grab the life that,
that life is an act of terror
and integrating beauty in the
ethical and aesthetic sense.
Overcoming the always
new barrier of cynicism
and disappointment,
demands sharpen
and arise every moment
the [inaudible] diversity
in front of us.
And now [inaudible] I will
hate sound like a self-help
or political correctness
preacher, but I am not wrong,
I know I am not wrong.
The eternal question about
identity also depends
on the fact that we are many
in search of the same answer
and on the way, it can be fun
and stimulating to recognize
that spark of similarity
and difference.
It is good to feel that
you belong to a place
but it is much better if you
can expand that landscape
and [inaudible] mysteries
from another universe.
During my time of
International Writing Program,
I saw how people love their own
language and at the same time,
develop new facets of themselves
in a temporary language.
Each contrast is
a new perspective
that allows the [inaudible]
to visit new regions
of their spiritual framework.
Writers, we are not easy
people but I think that most
of us start from the
fundamental conviction,
nothing important can be
accomplished without tolerance,
without the divine curiosity
that allows us to knock
on a door and peek through.
In Iowa I have the opportunity
to translate into Spanish poems
by authors that I have found
on my way and to listen
to my own work in
other languages.
A poem of mine in
Japanese was one
of the happiest revelations
of my life so far.
So, once again, it
is clear to me
that literature is a human
act and therefore political,
not because of its
implication or etiological uses,
but because it teaches us
nothing more and nothing less
than what we are made
of alone and together.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Christopher Merrill:
Thank you Enza,
and we can entertain
questions from the audience
and I think we have a microphone
that will be going around so
that we can capture
this for the recording.
And while we're waiting for you
for formulate some questions,
I think I might just say,
it seems to me that Santiago
and Enza both gave us
really wonderful definitions
of writing, maybe inadvertently
because Santiago described
what happened in the IWP
as a dynamic form
of organization
which also struck me as being
a good way to describe a novel,
right, as a dynamic
form of organization.
And Enza was talking about the
essential of integrating beauty
which is also what I think we
try to do as writers, and Amy,
it occurred to me when you
talked about Nikola Madzirov,
I recalled that during his
residency we had a night we
called global express
of staged plays
and that year we gave
the writers a prompt
and Nikola ended up writing
a short play together
with an Iranian poet and
they wrote it in English
and by the time the
play was staged,
neither one could remember
who had written which lines,
so I think that's another kind
of dynamic form of organization.
So, I'm just treading water
here looking for a question
and I have one here, first from
Australia and then from Nageire.
>> Thanks for [inaudible]
very much in agreement
with your argument for
[inaudible] and I wonder
if you're aware of any
others like yourself?
>> Amy Storrow: There are
four that I know of, yes.
And I would also invite
Professor Schneider
to come visit the Educational
and Cultural Affairs Bureau.
>> Cynthia P. Schneider: I
have, actually many times.
>> Amy Storrow: Oh,
I'm sure you have?
>> Cynthia P. Schneider:
And I don't want you
to misunderstand what I said, I
think you all do wonderful work.
I wish your colleagues and the
other [inaudible] would pay more
attention to the work you do.
>> Amy Storrow: I think it's
always a work in progress.
>> Cynthia P. Schneider:
That's my point,
not that you shouldn't
be doing what you do.
>> Amy Storrow: No, I know.
>> Cynthia P. Schneider:
But that other,
you shouldn't be isolated.
We talk about isolation
and integration and I wish
that you were not so isolated.
I wish that, you know,
people working on Pakistan
and Afghanistan were coming to
you and trying to understand
through writers,
that's all I mean.
>> Amy Storrow: For the record,
I actually don't feel isolated,
but thank you for your concern.
>> Cynthia P. Schneider:
Good, good.
>> Amy Storrow: And I don't
want to get to inside baseball
on this, but it's been really
fascinating to me working
in the Educational and
Cultural Affairs Bureau
to have the regionals come
to us over and over and ask
for more resources,
more programs.
It's been really wonderful.
>> Cynthia P. Schneider:
I'm so glad to hear it,
that is really fantastic.
I just, I might just go a
little bit to your question
since I was appointed
ambassador having served,
having been an art
historian my whole life
and having done 17th
century Dutch art
and travelled many times to
Holland and knew the language
and history and the culture
and I found that actually
that background as an academic,
I mean I taught at a university
where you basically have
to do a lot of research,
try to understand a new subject
and then talk about it to people
who may or may not agree
with what you're saying,
you're my students.
That was great background
to be an ambassador
because that's what you
have to do all the time
and I do remember, though, the
nervousness of my wonderful DCM
and officers the first time I
went to talk to the Administer
of Foreign Affairs and Minister
of Defense and there is,
I experienced this
kind of macho thing
where everybody else
can have like notepads
but the ambassador is not
supposed to, you're supposed
to know it and talk and not look
down to your little notebook
and I could see they were just
terrified and just had no idea
if I was going to know what
to say or start spouting off
about Rembrandt or something.
And it was hard, but I did
memorize a lot in my life
so I was able to talk about
strike fighters as much
as about Rembrandt, and I did
find that being able to make
that connection as someone
who had spent my career
up until then trying to
understand the culture
of the country where I was
serving, that meant so much
to the Dutch so that I was
able to take, you know,
the Prime Minister and
the Foreign Minister
around their own museums and
show them their exhibitions.
I also did that with
my own embassy staff.
There were some great
Rembrandt exhibitions and stuff,
so I got them all in when
the museums were closed and,
you know, was able to introduce
them to the local culture
as well, and I just would
mention that I also had,
every ambassador has, it
was a wonderful privilege
to have a collection
of art in the embassy.
Some go with their own
personal collections.
I did not have one and did
not do that, but with the help
of the fantastic bureau
at the State Department
that supports this program,
I was able to identify just
really fantastic works of art
that in one way or another
showed the connection
between the Netherlands
and the United States
from the Calder Mobile in the
front hall to Claes Oldenburg
to William De Kooning as well
as the great Rembrandt Peale
portrait of Thomas Jefferson
and you know, that was a regular
part of when people would come
to the residence, I
would give them the tour
and they would walk in and they
could see they may not know what
the works of were but they could
see right way that connection
and they loved seeing
that connection.
You know, they'd say wow a
new American artist thought
that much about Holland.
After, I'll just leave you
with one story of the impact
of culture, and this was
on someone who worked
at the embassy, I love this.
I left in June, 2001 so I
wasn't there for the fourth
of July party and someone I
encountered later in July said,
oh my gosh, I was just
at your residence,
I was there for the fourth
of July party and a member
of your staff gave a me a tour
of the collection that you had.
And I said, but it was
gone, all the paintings
and sculptures had been sent
back to their owners by then,
and the person said, yes
that's right, but the person
from your staff loved
that collection so much
that they took me through
the house and said,
this is what used to hang here,
and this is what it looked like
and this is why it was there.
So, that was one of my favorite
public diplomacy actions.
>> Yes, thank you very much
for your presentations,
I found them very fascinating.
I was listening to [inaudible]
but I have a question
for Amy Storrow.
You referred to active
cultural diplomacy on the ground
with a lot of open
mindedness and you know,
a lot of understanding
of the [inaudible]
on American cultural
regions, and I was wondering
if this was something
that was restricted
to a particular cultural
context, is this still going on,
would this be something
that would happen
like today, for example?
I ask this question
because as the director
of [inaudible] I have
a lot of relationships
with cultural diplomacy
of various countries,
including your own, and I have
had, I've heard the expression
that cultural diplomacy is
there to soften the ground
for political and [inaudible]
action and I'm wondering
which of these perspectives
correspond
to U.S. Cultural diplomacy let's
say, over the past 20 years.
>> Amy Storrow: That's a
wonderful, thank you Cynthia,
that's a wonderful question.
I think I'm going to
take, first the part of it
about when visitors come,
I think I can give a
really clear example,
so my first visitor, as I
mentioned, was Carolyn Forshay.
This was during the George
W. Bush administration time.
And she had some differences
with official policy
and so she gave a lot of
interviews and in some
of them she spoke against
official U.S. policy
and so I consulted
my boss, you know,
as a new officer what is
a guideline and he said,
this is freedom of
expression in action,
this is why we have people
of varying perspectives
give their views.
There was another, sort
of famous case of that
of Juno Diaz going
to Santa Domingo
and speaking very strongly
against official U.S. policy
and it really surprised
the people who live there
because they assumed that
somebody was being paid
by the government
on the program had
to speak that government line.
And for them, that
idea of freedom
of expression was
really eye opening.
As far as softening the ground
or not softening the ground,
I think people view these
things in different ways.
Sometimes people view
things as transactions,
I think that's a
very limited way
to view the world generally
speaking and ground comes
in all different
kinds of states,
but that we are all people
and the more we can learn
from each other the
better we all are.
>> [inaudible] Mexican
writer, and I was wondering,
and this is for everyone
[inaudible].
We know that languages create
traditions, literary traditions
in some way handling
American literature relying
to English tradition
and of course that's an American
tradition and Spanish tradition,
but how important
is it these days
if we could have
American tradition
across the whole continent like
we have the European tradition
in European literature, I think
how important it is to build
that tunnel or that wall that
they are building right now
that will open up a whole
literature of Americas
and we stop saying it's really
in English, or really in Spanish
and say it's really
on this continent
and it's really important
and matters to all of us
and what are the efforts
that are being done to build
that bridge, literature
bridge and break this idea
that it's English versus
Spanish, if America is one
and [inaudible] any
thoughts or ideas
of how build this
bridge [inaudible]
about the Americas
and not America?
>> Christopher Merrill:
Santiago or Enza?
Do you want to take that up?
>> Santiago Giralt: I think
is sounds utopian the idea
that we could breech
the language differences
because even in South America
the Portuguese who had the
like the population of
almost of all the rest
of the countries
together becomes a barrier
because translations are
[inaudible] so little
and I also feel like, in my
country in particular, literacy,
we have a big literacy,
like there's a lot
of literacy in Argentina.
I mean, kids could read,
but there's very
little public library's,
very little bookstores left.
Like there's some small towns
that don't even have
a bookstore.
Somehow, I still feel like
the fight has be again,
first it needs to be stronger
locally and it needs to be kind
of like pushed from
the local countries.
In Argentina, in Buenos Aries
luckily it seems like a paradise
because the bookstores
stay open until midnight
and there's beautiful caf's and
some big theaters have turned
into beautiful bookstores.
But if you go beyond the
borders of Buenos Aries,
the fights, it's strong.
Like I remember when I was
a kid, there was this truck
who would come to the
town with books and it was
like a [inaudible] bookstore and
I would go there and spend time
because my hometown had only one
library that was like really,
really, really old and
nobody wanted to have them.
So, I thing before that,
somehow, I feel like we have
to create readers for the
future because all the kids are
with their cell phones and with
their pads and stuff like that,
so in a way I feel that
before I could think
of this broader idea I think
with stronger literacy and more,
yeah, more access,
better access to books,
I think it's a fight I would go
for in my own country
to begin with.
>> Christopher Merrill:
Santiago, as you said that,
I was remembering being in Aman,
Jordon last December and we went
to an event and when we came
outside there was a car covered
with books and it turned out
it was this guy who would drive
from village to village to
sell books for, you know,
like a dollar and bought
a couple books from him.
I think, yeah.
>> First of all I'd like to
say hello to Christopher,
I haven't seen you
in almost a decade.
My name is Tracey [inaudible]
and I am a retired art historian
and for a number of years I
worked at the Hirshhorn Museum
and Sculpture Garden and
it was during that time
that through the Department
of State a colleague of mine,
we coordinated a program with
the International Writers
and The Hirshhorn had in place
a program called Music Art
to Inspire Writing and
the writers would come.
Do you still remember that?
And they would-- .
>> Christopher Merrill: I
also remember you sent one
of your great proteges to
the Des Moines Art Center
and she's still there,
I think, right?
>> Yes. And the writers would
come and read collectively
from the works in
one of the galleries
and the next day Christopher
would select a group of writers
who conducted a workshop
with the locals
who in turn produced
writing that was read
on Sunday afternoons and all
of this was put in a bulletin
and had quite a following and
he was there from 2002 to 2005.
So, I'd like to thank you and
I happened to get the email
and discovered that you
were going to be here,
that's why I came here and
invited my colleague [inaudible]
from Pennsylvania and she was
trying to get here to say hello
to you as well, so I'm
very happy to be a part
of this program,
thank you so much.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Christopher Merrill:
Let's go here and here.
>> Hi, I'm just wanting to
add [inaudible] to the comment
about [inaudible] because I've
been in the business sector
for a very long time and one
of my exit interviews was
about the [inaudible] for women
directors [inaudible] I just
wanted to ask, to what extent
do you have your writing
[inaudible] your writing goes
to the masses of ordinary people
because one of the
best things I've found
in Iowa was not the readings
of the people [inaudible],
the readings to the community.
Because it was just amazing
that their questions [inaudible]
so how did you do that
in your own countries?
>> Enza Garcia Arreaza: I
think, I don't have that in mind
when I'm writing
because it's dangerous.
I just want to write for
the people who is there
in that moment, for someone
who needs to read that story
that I brought to life.
And I don't know, I mean, after
my last book, someone told me,
oh I don't like anymore
your writing
because you're not sexy
anymore, you write now a lot
about Japanese reference,
now your characters talk
about the books they are
reading in that moment.
Your writing now
is like too serious
for a small group of people.
And well, I don't know, it's
sad but I don't want to write
for a specific audience,
I just want to be
who I am when I write.
The other day, with Natasha
in the class, I said something
that really moves me now, I
said, you know I hate people,
it's difficult for me to be
among a crowd but when I write,
I really love the things,
the words, the characters,
the humanity, so in the end
I really love that person
that I am when I write.
And that's it.
Thank you.
>> Santiago Giralt: What I could
add only is as a film maker,
you have more pressure from the
production structure to think
about your viewers
because it's a more,
although the publishing
industry could be tough,
the film industry there's so
much money you have to back
that they really think
about the audience,
so you are in this conversation,
sometimes you get these screen
tests that are really weird.
So, that's why I
do the [inaudible]
to be free from that.
And to expand the
possibilities of that.
I also got my first novel
got published by mistake
because it was financed for
this international price
so I didn't even, like think it
would be published so quickly.
So, yeah, I really, but what I
really love from literature is
that the feedback that you
get from your readers it's
so intimate, it feels,
people like talking
about themselves much more
than when they're talking
about movies because a movie
is more like a social thing
and literature is so private.
Even my mother reads
my novels like my diary
and so goes crazy every time.
I also wanted to say that
I would like to remember
so other Argentinian
writers that came
to the International
Writers Program.
One of them happens to be
one of my greatest friend.
He's [inaudible] and [inaudible]
another writer/director,
Christina Pena, like I know
many of them and I really think
through the years many people
who have been lucky enough
to be part of the program have
become lamplights for the,
how you say, lanterns,
yeah, for all the ones
who were coming behind,
so I even wanted to come
to the International Writers
Program when I read it
in the cover of one
of [inaudible] books,
he's one of my favorite writer,
oh what is this, I
want to go to it.
It's also, it becomes a utopian
place to be a part when you feel
like your country is not really
getting your inner poetry,
you inner self and so, yeah.
>> Christopher Merrill: I'm
so glad you mentioned Martine,
who is both a fiction writer
and a film maker and that year,
for a variety of reasons,
the writers had roommates
and his roommate was the
playwright Mike Finn,
and I said to him one day,
so, how is it with Martine
and he said, well you know, I
wasn't really planning to write,
I was planning to
enjoy myself here
but Martine writes everyday
so, now I'm writing.
There was a question here?
>> So this for both Amy Storrow
and Ambassador Schneider.
I'm wondering, from
being out in the field,
did you see other countries
doing cultural diplomacy,
did you see them
doing it differently,
do you see this agenda
being more important
for like the smaller countries
or perhaps other
larger countries?
>> Cynthia P. Schneider: Well,
I might tie an answer to that
into coming back to the
other Cynthia's question
when you were asking about
culture kind of softening,
softening the ground and I think
that there is also this
entity called public diplomacy
which is different from
cultural diplomacy, particularly
as hearing about it
practiced here and the larger
in the United States
State Department,
the largest bureau
is public diplomacy
with the mission really of
promoting the understanding
and acceptance of
America's policies,
which is think is a fabulous
idea from the 1950's and not
so appropriate now in this
age of global communications
and fortunately, you
can talk about this more
but I have the sense that the
way cultural diplomacy operates
is more in the way
of cultural relations
and interestingly enough,
the British have gotten rid
of the word cultural
diplomacy, and just talk
about cultural relations.
I think to avoid the
idea of what you said,
that this is not a kind of
backdoor way into getting you
to accept what other nefarious
policy we want you to accept
so while you're up watching a
science movie we're doing this,
and you know, and even, and
cultural diplomacy is a term
which I've used a lot, I'm
increasingly troubled with it
because it has that kind
of sense of, I have a goal
and I'm going to use
this to get to that goal,
but I think what you've heard
today is much more in the nature
of cultural relations and
cultural exchange, whatever,
you know, whatever
it might be called.
I've seen some examples, I
think that I really admire
that are more in the way of this
leveraging local voices idea,
and it is often the
smaller countries,
although Great Britain has bee
doing this for a long time and,
you know, the whole structure is
different with other countries
where they tend to, Great
Britain, France, Italy, Spain,
they all have, Scandinavian
countries,
they all have a slightly
separate arm's length division
that takes care of culture and
so, they're a little bit less,
in my experience, I'm sure
there's some exceptions to this,
but there may be
a little bit less
about promoting their
culture per se
as leveraging local cultures.
I saw for example a fantastic,
no you don't think so,
well I'll just give you a couple
of examples that I have seen,
they may not do it all the time,
but a fantastic hip hop event
that the Scandinavians did in
Alexandria in Egypt bringing,
you know, providing a stage and
a platform and the opportunity
to perform to local hip hop
groups, which they don't have
but that's what they want, to be
able to reach their audiences.
At the same time, the way
this may have changed,
this was about six
or seven years ago,
at the same time the
United States policy was
to send American
artists to places,
so those are two
different approaches.
I'll give one other example that
I think was really brilliant,
which is what Great Britain
did during the Olympics
with Shakespeare and it was
a fantastic way, I think,
of showing how global
Shakespeare is and that is
that they invited performances
of different Shakespeare plays
in local languages
and in local idioms
and they were performed
every night at the Globe.
And you know, I don't know
who assigned the plays,
it was kind of weird, like
China had Richard the Third
and of all things, Pakistan
had the Taming of the Shrew.
So, there were some odd things,
but the plays were really
incredible and what a way,
you know, without saying,
Shakespeare is global,
it just came out through
all the performances.
>> Amy Storrow: I would say
it a tiny bit differently
but not hugely, from my
perspective and I think
from the perspective of
the State Department,
cultural diplomacy is
part of public diplomacy
and it's also a subset
of exchange programs.
So, one interesting thing,
you are all exchange program
participants who came here
on J-Visa's, which are
foreign exchange programs.
It's how many of them
are bilateral agreements?
So, for example, the Fulbright
program I believe that funding
from Germany is three times
the amount of American funding
that goes into the
Fulbright Program.
So, many of these programs are
in fact, they go both ways,
so the more that we can
collaborate with each other
and not view it as a
competition, I think is great.
There are models out
there that I admire,
I think that what the Brits
do, or what the British do
with English in particular
is very impressive,
but I think we've all got a
lot to learn from each other
and I do want to go back
to the softening the
ground comment for a second.
It's an interesting idea but
I don't think that life works
that way, hahaha, we're going
to send Cynthia on a program
and then or nefarious plan next,
to go back to Ambassador
Schneider,
then this will happen, you know,
like it's far to complicated
and complex for that
kind of thinking
for that to really work.
I am a kind of true believer
and a purist in a lot of ways.
And I really, really believe
that exchange programs
and cultural programs,
but all kinds
of exchange programs are what
make the world a stronger,
safer, better place.
Right now, around the world,
one-third of all current heads
of state or current heads of
government, exchange alumni
of U.S. Government funded
programs like this one.
It's a tremendous
legacy that you share,
you as alumni, or
as almost alumni.
>> [inaudible] and I'd
like to make a comment
about Professor Schneider
[inaudible] presentation.
It is so important
that indeed poetry
and writers are [inaudible]
in many countries.
In Chili [inaudible] a
national day of mourning
and this [inaudible]
in Latin America
and [inaudible] in
the United States.
So, thank you for
explaining all that.
Excellent.
>> Christopher Merrill:
Thank you.
>> Cynthia P. Schneider:
You know,
I would just recall a former
poet laurate, Robert Pinsky,
here who had a wonderful project
called the Favorite Poem Project
that he did around
the year 2000.
And, just to say, I think
it is absolutely true
that we don't have the same, I
think we do have the same kind
of public intellectuals
but again,
for whatever reason we
don't take them as seriously
as they are in other countries,
which are absolutely right
and Palestine [inaudible]
is really the founder
of the country or Iqbal
or Pakistan, and yet,
why don't we automatically
say Walt Whitman here.
I don't know, but Robert
kind of punctured that idea
with his wonderful Favorite
Poem Project where he,
and this was before
the internet really,
he was really interviewing
people all over the country,
all different walks of life,
asking them what was
their favorite poem,
and the book puts
it all together,
the construction worker
loves Walt Whitman
and the Cambodian refugee
loves Langston Hughes,
there's two examples I remember,
but these are very much people
from all walks of life for whom
poetry is really important.
So, I think it's out
there but somehow,
we just don't see it as much.
>> Amy Storrow: I think
that Chili had some model
of Neruda to draw from.
Yes, yes, as a diplomatic
poet and I read once
that more Neruda has published
more books than any other work
of literature except
for the bible.
So, that is a global
legacy right there.
>> Christopher Merrill:
We were getting the look
but hands keep going up.
>> Rob Casper: I think
we're going to end things.
You do have the opportunity,
though, if you want to talk
to all of our panelist
afterwards, please do so.
[inaudible] showed herself.
Mary Jane Deeb, the chief
of the African Middle
Eastern division is here.
Our areas study divisions
have amazing reading rooms
and if you're not
scheduled to go see them,
African Middle Eastern,
Hispanic, European and Asian,
you should check them out
today while you're here
and maybe meet the curators
that are responsible
for your countries.
But for now, let's
thank our panelists,
thanks so much for being here.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.